pleased to have back here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is a guy
who is having an incredible season for
the arizona cardinals to say the least
his 12 rushing touchdowns by a cardinals
player through the team's first 11 games
is a franchise record
one or more rushing touchdowns in eight
of the last 11 games this season that's
tied for most in the nfl with jonathan
taylor here he is from the arizona
cardinals fresh off of a dub in front of
the 12s in seattle is james connor how
are you doing james
man rich i'm feeling really good brother
i'm feeling good how are you you should
you know part of the reason why i want
to have you on is not only because your
team's doing so well and you're doing so
well it's it's thanksgiving week man
it's thanksgiving week and your story is
incredible and you must have a ton to be
thankful for james connor i would
imagine
every day every day we got so much to be
thankful for you know really blessed and
uh
yeah so man we uh got a good victory you
know now we're heading into our bye week
is thanksgiving i can eat me a couple
plates yep you know recover the body so
i got a lot to look forward to king of
playing a couple of plates a couple of
plates are you giving warning to
whoever's house you're going to or
whoever's coming to your house james is
that is yeah you're laying down your
market
it's been some time since i got to you
know eat some good thanksgiving food and
not have to worry about playing you know
in a couple of days and whatnot so
i'm gonna take full advantage well it's
a bye week i'd just say screw it just
take the belt off
exactly you know so what what is going
so well for you this year james to what
do you owe your personal professional
success this year be easy that's my
faith um you know coming into the season
uh just you know and then just my faith
growing uh you know throughout time but
you know just giving god the glory for
everything and i'm just letting him
leave my life you know being my guidance
and direction and all that
and so that's first and foremost but
then also just um you know just playing
my role to the fullest uh you know i
doing just doing everything that the
cardinals asked me to do
and uh playing for my teammates team is
coming together you know we're playing
for one another
and um just understand the pieces we got
and what the job is what the mission is
what the goal is and you know just just
fighting for that so just a little bit
everything faith and hard work and i'm
just wondering if if you you kind of
touched on it here and i guess i'm going
to put a finer point on it if you don't
mind in pittsburgh you were viewed as
le'veon bell's successor you were viewed
as the guy that was going to come in
certainly since the fan base knew you
knew your story since you played your
college ball there you were right front
and center there you're from the state
um and and is it i guess a better fit
for you in the long run
that you were brought to arizona and
they're just like you just do your thing
you're not you're not you're not the
next anything you're you're the james
connor that the arizona cardinals wanted
is there anything to that do you think
james uh yeah you know i just i just
felt like um you know all things were
new for me so you know
i just embraced the change you know uh
you know it gave him all out there in
pittsburgh and you know after the after
after my four years was up you know just
you know um it was i guess you know it
wasn't for them so i just you know just
continued to trust my work trust my
faith and uh
just figured out what the you know to
sat down and prayed about i see what the
best decision was for me and uh it led
me to a z and uh they embraced me you
know with open arms my teammates the
coaching staff everybody so
um you know just playing for them now uh
you know that's just kind of this is
god's plan for me how things worked out
so what about the scheme fits for you do
you think james what about that um you
know i think uh you know it's it's you
know with the weapons that we have on
our side and you know qb like kyla
murray um you know they really upgraded
the line uh out here so it's just a you
know a combination of a lot of things
and um you know me just being playing my
role you know the short yardage and you
know but that's expanded you know just
trying to show you know i'm versatile in
all parts of the game but it's just
playing my role in doing what they asked
me to do
and i i just embrace that and so you
know it's it's working and we got a lot
more work to do though james connor here
on the rich eisen show i know you've
been there you've done that but what's
it like getting in the huddle looking up
that's kyla murray giving you the play
and you look around there's aj green and
that's deandre hopkins what's that
man it's special it's uh it's fun it's a
lot of fun out there you know collar is
so exciting and then obviously you know
hop and aj and you know even got zach
earth now and you know ronnie hudson in
the middle humping like you know we just
got we got pieces man we got a lot of
players but we also got a lot of you
know guys who love the game and
and play for one another so it's
definitely exciting being on the field
out there with you know with those guys
okay and then uh kingsbury he seems like
he's got a little bit of the crazy in
him he's been on this show what do you
think i mean he's also went then he got
is wasn't he called flag for barking at
somebody who was barking at him the
other day
there's josh norman right it's josh
norman i think so yeah in san fran but
uh that's coach man he's
so passionate man uh you know every day
he brings his juice and you know just
tries to get the most out of us and he
puts so much effort into the game so
coach is just a passion to do man and uh
we love playing for him and and you know
he's just all laying on us we all in on
him like i said before there's gonna be
a lot of coach of the year talk for him
it always is for a team that's sitting
in a one seat on on thanksgiving weekend
will be regardless of the results in
thanksgiving week that's always that
surrounding and obviously colt mccoy
just came up with a couple of w's for
you guys on the road with you guys on
the road give me a good story about
kingsbury that would uh that would put
that coach of the year resume on the
table you got a good one for you for me
for that sort of no no specific stories
but you know if coach wants to coach you
know coach you know he's 100 deserving
of it you know he would you know i know
his work doesn't know he comes to work
every day and you know how hard he works
so
um you know he's deserving of it and so
uh i think he should you know i think
he'd won for it okay uh what about colt
mccoy he said it was his responsibility
to win games on the road uh what do you
think about his performance over the
last three weeks
james
every day out of his approach to
practicing and coming to play and uh you
know mccoy so you know he got a resume
so
um
you know he got the job done and that's
what we expect you know so that's what
we expect out of colt you know he's a
winner as well so
um we ride with him you talking about
super bowl openly
do we talk about the super bowl openly
yes sir we talk about going 1-0 each
week um we talked about being able to
you know win this game on the road in
seattle before our bye weekend you know
having one of the best records and
getting our bodies back and then we got
chicago december 5th so that's what we
talk about going one or no the word
super bowl have never been put together
by anybody in your team in a locker room
come on now james oh they probably have
it's just not the topic of discussion
you know
maybe
you know maybe
it's not it's not something that we all
get together and discuss we discuss
going one and those so when the super
bowl comes and we go want to know then
there you go all right let's talk about
you a little bit how's your health
you're good it's all good for you oh man
i'm healthy i'm healthy yes sir okay and
so you know again i mean it's it's it's
such a terrific
you know rise that you've had since your
your college year diagnosis and where
you are
now i i'm wondering if i had went up to
that kid who had gotten that diagnosis
after tearing up his knee in college um
that this was going to happen in 2021
what would you have said
at that time james uh
i'd have told him i told him stay
patient keep working uh
trust the faith try to process embrace
the journey the journey is the
destination
you know um so you know just been
through a lot of things just like
anybody else um
you know who's to say minds is worse
than what somebody else went through you
know it was a struggle for sure but it's
just my story so i chose to embrace that
and uh always you know i would say also
say use your imagination you know when i
was
you know getting that chemotherapy
sitting there i always imagined would it
be like running on the nfl stage scoring
touchdowns in the nfl you know you got
to see it first before you know you
actually do it so
i would just tell them stay patient stay
strong keep god first and use your
imagination that's beautiful so when you
seriously so you're you're you're
getting your chemotherapy um as a
college player you're dreaming of stuff
like you're doing right now like you did
just yesterday is that what you're
saying every day every day yeah chemo
takes about four hours
so you know i had a lot of time to just
sit on youtube and
watch highlights and
and just dream wow you know i was doing
that
and what would you say to people right
now who might be going through that with
a family member on thanksgiving week
james oh man you know i
i got actually diagnosed a couple couple
days before thanksgiving so um i would
tell them i know what they're going
through but you know like my mother told
me um
you know and then i she said it was
gonna be all temporary and you know
unfort you know unfortunately that's not
the the case and and you know in all
cancer cases you know sometimes
you know the outcome you know isn't what
we expect or what we want but um man my
mother told me it was gonna be temporary
and i just i truly believed that so
that's what i would
you know tell somebody that's temporary
and just keep going first and just trust
it because you know in a situation like
that um
you know you need you need strength from
somewhere else no doubt about that where
are you going to be spending
thanksgiving itself do you know i'm
going to go back home i'm going to go
back home from home and get and see my
family see all my brothers and
you know and my parents and all them and
uh get some good meals and get some good
fellow shipping with them your dad still
riding around that sweet ride you
surprised him with a couple years ago
he's still in the truck he's still in a
pickup truck he's enjoying it up there
so he's still in the truck he's still on
the connor mobile pretty much okay
all right and again i guess last last
one for you james can you
can you put into words what it's going
to feel like for you to walk through
that door with your record the way it is
and your performance the way that it has
been and your story
being is what it is to use the football
phrase what is that going to feel like
for you to walk through that door for
thanksgiving and see your family james
oh man i'm still the youngest i got i
got five older brothers man and uh
you know so they they they love me
dearly and you know proud of everything
i've been doing but at the end of the
day you know i'm still this little bro
to them so
um it'll be you know what does that mean
what do you mean by that what do you
mean
what's that gonna what do you what does
that entail being the leader that i mean
i mean they're gonna put me right back
in my place when i come home
okay
all right now they they just gonna be
cool it's just gonna be family time you
know uh you know i'm gonna see my
nephews and it's just gonna be you know
we'll talk a little ball but we'll just
enjoy each other's company you know so
that's that's pretty much it any turkey
bowl like anything in the backyard in
the front yard or you you're you
obviously can't participate in that
because you you would skew the sides if
you did something like that
you know there's no turkey rolling like
that if we do i'll be all-time qb or
something like that you know how it goes
i do i do know how it goes have a great
thanksgiving travel safe and let's do
this again real soon james congrats on
everything all right happy thanksgiving
right back at you that's james connor
right here on the rich eisen show how
neat is that gonna be for him to walk in
that door
with all these touchdowns this year
under his belt he's nine and two
honestly you have to you have to
put it all in perspective with his
journey and
and his
you know being cancer-free
and he was a house of fun i remember
when le'veon was holding out and he did
so well and he had that high ankle
sprain and then got hurt and then really
wasn't the same after that for
pittsburgh and this year it would be oh
where's james connor arts right he's in
arizona
well kenyon drake's now in vegas so
that's gonna be chase edmonds job what's
james connor going to do
we can see what he's done
score a lot of touch though he's scoring
a lot of touchdowns and he's also not
allowing his team to settle for field
goals
what's what a difference maker that is
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here